president biden is defending the
nation's top general after calls for him
to resign
a new book says that general mark milley
chairman of the joint chiefs of staff
told china that the u.s was not going to
start a war in the final months of the
trump administration the former
president and other critics say that
millie went beyond his authority and
undermined civilian control of the
military ed o'keefe is at the white
house with more on this story ed good
morning to you gail great to see you the
pentagon says that general milley's
interactions with chinese military
officials were just part of his normal
interactions with global military
leaders but a new book reports millie
feared that former president trump had
gone into a serious mental decline in
the aftermath of the election and might
go rogue launching a strike against
china the authors write that compelled
millie to reach out to china's top
military official twice last october and
in early january just two days after the
insurrection at the capitol
multiple republican lawmakers say this
was an effort to work around former
president trump and a reason that the
general should resign be fired or face
some kind of military justice but
president biden and his top aides are
standing by the general
i have great confidence in general
miller the president has complete
confidence in his leadership his
patriotism and his fidelity to our
constitution
the defense secretary lloyd austin also
expressing support for the general as
for former president trump he calls this
report fabricated and says he never even
considered some kind of a strike against
china we should point out these details
are coming in a new book it's called
peril it's by washington post reporters
bob woodward and robert costa published
by simon schuster a division of viacom
cbs
tony
all right ed thank you very much